The original Star Wars trilogy is constantly
evolving and that's not necessarily a good
thing.
Now, with the arrival of Disney+, we've been
given yet another version of Star Wars: A
New Hope, the very first film in the franchise.
And this version includes a head-scratching
change to A New Hope's most controversial
scene: The moment when "Han shoots first"
… or does he?
Now, technically, this new change wasn't Disney's
doing.
Like all the other perplexing Star Wars changes
that have been made since the "Special Editions"
were first released in 1997, this latest edit
is the work of creator George Lucas.
He's still finding new, groundbreaking ways
to rile up Star Wars fans, all these years
after selling the franchise.
This was confirmed in a statement that Disney
gave to ComicBook.com:
"The change was made by George Lucas, prior
to the Disney acquisition."
Meanwhile, in a Twitter exchange between Uproxx
Senior Entertainment Editor Mike Ryan and
longtime Lucasfilm employee Pablo Hidalgo,
Ryan tweeted:
"I just watched the new Greedo scene from
the first Star Wars.
WHAT ON EARTH?!?!"
Hidalgo responded:
"Ah, I see D+ must have the 4K version.
[...] This would've been done a few years
back, by Lucas.
A final 4K restoration in anticipation of
a 3D re-release that never happened after
3D re-releases fizzled."
In the latest version of the scene, bounty
hunter Greedo utters a perplexing word right
before his infamous shootout with Han Solo…
and it's really quite the doozy.
"Maclunkey!"
Maclunkey?
Thanks for clearing that up!
There are no subtitles when Greedo shouts
this strange word even though we're treated
to subtitles for the rest of Greedo's dialogue
throughout the scene.
So what does it mean, exactly?
Well, Slate helpfully points out that
"'Ma klounkee' is a phrase used in The Phantom
Menace [...] which is translated in the subtitles
as […] 'It will be the end of you.'"
"Next time we race, boy, it will be the end
of you."
If we have our dates correct, Lucas made this
change prior to selling Lucasfilm to Disney
in 2012, but after the film's last Blu-ray
release in 2011.
That's a pretty small window.
In the original cut of the scene the one that
played in theaters in 1977 there's absolutely
no question that Han shoots first.
That's why he's slyly pulling his blaster
from its holster while chatting up Greedo.
Not only does Han shoot first, Han only shoots!
Greedo doesn’t even get off a shot.
Try putting that on a t-shirt…
It's a cold-blooded move but actually rather
important for his character arc, since he
becomes a better man over the course of the
film.
Well, for the film's 1997 Special Edition
re-release, Lucas altered the scene so that
Greedo fires a shot at Han and misses, prompting
Han to fire back in self defense.
This change absolves Han of any questionable
behavior, but one could argue that it also
makes his character arc less compelling.
Still, George Lucas doesn't see it that way
at all.
As he told The Hollywood Reporter in 2012,
"[The re-edit] upset people because they wanted
Solo to be a cold-blooded killer, but he actually
isn't."
Where do you stand on this brouhaha?
"Sorry about the mess."
Following the release of next month's Star
Wars Episode IX: The Rise of Skywalker, the
immediate future of Star Wars hinges on Disney+.
Luckily for fans, the streaming service has
big plans in store for the franchise, and
you can stream the original trilogy, the prequel
trilogy, Rogue One: A Star Wars Story, and
Star Wars Episode VII: The Force Awakens.
Meanwhile, The Last Jedi and Solo: A Star
Wars Story will hit the streamer when current
distribution agreements expire.
Disney+ will also be streaming The Rise of
Skywalker once the film leaves theaters.
Right now, you can also stream The Clone Wars
on Disney+ both the film and the series.
Or go nuts and stream Star Wars Rebels, Star
Wars Resistance, loads of Lego Star Wars content,
shorts, and documentaries and, of course,
The Mandalorian , the new series created by
Jon Favreau that's raking in rave reviews.
There's also a live-action series in the works
that will follow the adventures of Rogue One's
Cassian Andor, as well as the recently-announced
and long-anticipated live-action Obi-Wan Kenobi
series.
That will star Ewan McGregor, reprising his
role as the Jedi Master after portraying him
in the prequel films.
In other words, Disney+ is shaping up to be
the go-to destination for fans to get their
Star Wars fix for the next few years.
Until then… may the force be with you.
Oh, and one more thing:
"Maclunkey!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.